people are speculating about children I
mean that's the next step in a marriage
so who knows maybe a ball will see iris
full belly and with child's nowhere it
shouldn't be here have we met
no no I'm a complete and total stranger
I don't always pay no worse I'm thinking
about trying my hand at something new
like what for starters training someone
to take over there's another flash on
your it will be as soon as I'm done
training her hey everybody its charlie I
wanted to do a flash season five arrow
season seven video because arrow in
particular just teed up a really big
criminal organization there was a scene
that literally reads like hey we're
gonna be bringing this back in season
seven you've just met the villains of
season seven flash season five stuff is
all part of this coffee shop girl flash
family-centric more time travel based
stuff but it also goes back to what
abracadabra said if you're new to the
channel I do a flash ring giveaway every
week all you have to do to enter just be
a subscriber leave a comment on the
video let's start with a flash stuff
first so coffee shop girl in abracadabra
from last season a couple other scenes
that Barry iris and Jay Garrick have had
this season that let you know what's
coming next these are things that we
plan to do coffee shop girl is the thing
that everyone's talking about I think
you know the twist of twist that we're
expecting is that it won't be tornado
twins dawn and dawn
it'll be Nora Allen she'll be named
after Barry's mother I shouldn't be here
Nora isn't supposed to be here is one of
the gibberish lines that he had at the
very beginning of the season when he was
scribbling those future speedforce
symbols they said that they weren't
doing a lot of time travel of this
season but coffee shop girl herself is
confirmed to be from the future so
they've already done an element of time
travel it seems like next season will
slowly get back to that because you
bring flash family from the future you
start to tease more flash family based
stories you have to incorporate some
elements of time travel but just because
you're doing flash family doesn't mean
you have to get really crazy with it
like Mark Waid era where you deal with
the reverse-flash family Malcolm Thawne
it gets really nuts I don't think
they're gonna be doing anything like
that but then you have scenes like
abracadabra zit
the end of season 3 where they Babe Ruth
style call their shot and give you a
teaser for things to come like at the
end of season 1 with all those different
scenes here's killer frost here's berry
in jail like we saw during season four
here's the flash Museum so there are
things that they've done this season
that tell you where they're headed next
so think about the really big scenes the
idea that you're looking more to the
future like you have villains from the
future coming back into the past you
have family members from the future
coming back into the past it sounds like
if copy shop girl is really just like a
minor character this season if they want
to bring her back it will have to be a
more flash family future based storyline
next season the thing about the flash
and it's also true of arrow is that no
matter where they go they always have a
base of operations that they come back
to where most of the team stays so
that's always gonna be STAR Labs in
present day will always come back to
that no matter where Barry goes or where
the villains come from but one of the
important and very easy slam-dunk things
that I think that the flash TV show can
do to make it more relevant more
relatable for people that aren't comic
book fans and more exciting for comic
book fans at the same time is to do a
more flash family-centric story as long
as they can balance all those characters
well because you can't really do flash
family without doing Wally but it almost
seems like he's still gonna be on
legends of tomorrow next season so he's
a bit of a question mark but they've
kind of been teasing the progression of
Barry and iris of relationship Candice
Patton herself has teased the idea that
someday she'd like to see iris be
pregnant and have a baby on the show we
just screams flash family based story
it's just the easiest thing to do
most of the flash comics the biggest
stories or flash family centric stories
but in the short term what'll probably
happen at the end of the season is is
cisco goes off to help and the
other breachers during the break like he
says okay you know I'm gonna go away for
a while they'll find a reason for him to
come back during season five
Caitlin right now seems like she still
doesn't have her powers unless they
fixed that in the next couple of
episodes the break for her will probably
be her trying to find a way back to her
killer frost powers and just going back
to her old life like after season one
where she became a researcher at mercury
labs just doing normal stuff Barry and
iris during the break pretty easy slam
dunk they said that they were going to
be spending time doing husband why
married couple stuff there like we
haven't been doing much of that since we
got married we need to do that so
probably just a vacation for them
hopefully Wally comes back and they'll
just have him watch the city while
they're on vacation because they're
finally going to reveal who coffee shop
girl is in the finale I'm expecting that
once they explain it she'll go back to
the future like okay I've done what I
came here to do I need to go back but
because she's a relatively notable
actress and the character seems really
interesting I would like to see them
bring her back regardless of what kind
of flash family story they do you know
really just depend on how they spiked
that ball like they make her nor Alan
she's Barry's daughter but do they want
to make her a version of the tornado
twins or do they want to make her a
version of Bart Allen and she's a
speedster the last little bit to Jay
Garrick said that he was going to be
training a female speedster to take his
place on earth three if that's not gonna
be Jesse quick it's probably gonna be
coffee shop girl meaning that she would
permanently come from the future to stay
in present-day
which would be more of a Bart Allen
style story the reason that Bart came
from the future was a little bit
different so I'm expecting whatever the
flash TV show does with some of these
characters in these storylines to be a
little bit different when it comes to
arrow talking about the Diaz episode
that they just had you guys probably
heard about the quadrant you're like
wait a minute is that like the ninth
circle from the Green Arrow comics
because that would be a really cool
season 7 storyline so what are they done
every season on arrow
Oliver tries to protect his city in
varying ways at varying degrees season
one is about the list he's just checking
off names of bad guys in the city season
2 he pays the consequences
Slade tries to destroy his city for his
actions during season 1 in season two
you get to season 3 season 4 season 5 he
still tries to save his city season 2
season but he tries to affect change on
a larger scale so eventually he becomes
mayor so he can affect policy obviously
that isn't working out for him right now
how do you escalate beyond that in
season 7 well in this last episode they
said the quadrant controls all crime in
the United States and while Diaz
hilariously offs one of the members so
that he has a seat on the quadrant now
they tease the idea that the
organization is extremely powerful so
it's just sort of a one-off case that
he's able to easily kill one of those
members it's not like he's gonna be able
to do that to every single one of them
so the quadrant then says that they're
going to turn star city into their port
of call where they can ship all of their
drugs illegal goods into the country and
Oliver obviously is it going to be
really happy with that so that sounds
like a season seven plot Oliver makes a
list but it's a nationwide list so he
has a reason to keep coming back to Star
City because that's where the quadrant
is going to be centering a lot of his
shipping operations so they can still do
stories within star city so you can
bounce around the rest of team arrow but
Oliver can also take it on the road and
track down these other people that have
criminal enterprises all over the United
States like I said the quadrant on the
TV show just like the ninth circle in
the comics more Raquin Robert Queen were
members of that so it's sort of like the
shadow organization that they tease
during arrow season one like Robert
Queen and the other people on the list
we're all in league together in their
criminal enterprise within the city the
quadrant the ninth circle are just
bigger versions of that let me know in
the comments though all the teasers that
we've gotten for next season of the
flash do you think they're going to be
doing a more flash family centric
storyline regardless of who the villain
ends up being and then on arrow do you
think that the quadrant will become the
main villain of season seven what'll
happen is is obviously next week is
pretty much infinity war week there will
be new arrow new flash so I'll be doing
those videos in between all the infinity
war stuff my non-spoilery infinity war
review will post on Tuesday so don't
worry I'll just be posting video updates
there's a new Witcher video that I want
to do it probably won't post til later
tonight so there'll be like a late night
Saturday video but Westworld season 2
also starts on Sunday what you wait for
everything click here for that brand new
Deadpool trailer and click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight